I have a new update I contacted the
engineering department at NASA and found
out the new Rover is using the same
memory platform used on curiosity and
the Curiosity rover was equipped with
two computers but only one was active at
a time and it had the following specs
two gigabytes of flash memory 256
megabytes of random access memory and
256 kilobytes of read-only memory which
held core system routines we want to be
able to store our entire program in RAM
however because we have to share this
space with other programs we are
allocated 5% of RAM which is the maximum
we can use and this is about twelve
point eight megabytes total I bring this
up because I want to introduce the idea
of time-space trade-off or space-time
trade-off a commonly used term in
computer science I was looking at a
program done by Ivy 46 and they had a
million prime array so that their
algorithm could step along on Prime's
only as far as possible when doing a
trial division primality test and it
begs the question why not just store all
the Prime's we need up to some limit in
an array instead of calculating them on
the fly we mentioned in a previous video
that this would be optimal for a trial
division algorithm
although you may see his algorithm does
not use many steps it began to run very
slowly and eventually crashed before
hitting the step limit so it wasn't able
to quickly solve the problem for the
size as I defined earlier and in this
case they were trading off time in the
form of repeated divisibility tests at
the expense of space which is memory to
hold the array now why didn't this work
well let's do a rough calculation using
what we've learned to find out if this
method is possible using our memory
limit remember we must be able to deal
with numbers up to just over 9
quadrillion and our trial division
algorithms only need to check for
factors up to the square root of a
number and if it hits that point with no
factors found it can say 100% whether or
not the number is prime now how many
Prime's up to the square root of this
limit where the square root of 9
quadrillion is 94 point nine million how
many Prime's under 95 million well
luckily we have learned a mathematical
solution to approximate this answer
using the prime number theorem
so how many Prime's are there under X
well it's X divided by the natural
logarithm of X and if X is just over
94.9 million we find the number of
primes is approximately five point 1
million now because we are storing these
primes we need to know the size of the
largest prime or in this case the five
point one millionth prime approximately
which we know will be some number less
than ninety four point nine million now
I double-checked the table and the
actual value of this Prime the largest
prime we would need to store under the
square root of our limit is 89 million
78640 find out let's convert the number
into binary notation which is how the
computer will store the number using
tiny switches in memory we learned about
this in the computer memory video in
bits the largest prime looks like this
which is 24 bits or three bytes needed
to store this single number so let's say
we want to store each number in memory
and since we know the largest number
requires 24 bits we can just imagine a
long list of 24 bit blocks storing each
prime number so how many bits are needed
for this entire list well the memory
needed is the number of values or the
number of primes times the space per
value so we have around five point 1
million values times 24 bits per value
which is just over 124 million bits or
if we converted into bytes
it's about fourteen point seven million
bytes call this almost 15 megabytes so
it is not possible to store even a list
of these numbers in memory using our
lemon and this is just a toy example
it's actually an underestimation of what
you'd really need for example an array
needs space for a pointer to each eye
and each pointer on a 32-bit machine is
4 bytes so the actual amount of memory
needed is much more than 15 megabytes
that being said we know that storing all
Prime's up to the square root of our
relatively small limit is not even
possible with our memory limit we can't
do it this way
okay well what about when prices drop by
a factor of a thousand or ten thousand
modern-day cryptographic systems use 512
bit or even larger numbers making search
and enumeration impossible now for
example if someone asks you to make a
list of all prime numbers up to Prime's
which are 200 digits in length
you shouldn't even consider it because
the hard drive needed to store all these
primes would be heavier than the mass of
the observable universe
I'll leave the calculations for you to
try next time you're at a restaurant
with crayons and paper all over the
table but remember there are around 10
to the 80 atoms in the observable
universe
that's an 80 digit number
realize now there is a fundamental limit
for how much space or memory we have
access to never mind how much time it
would take but there is always this push
and pull between using space or time to
solve our problems so to solve this
problem of testing for prime allottee
quickly using a small amount of space
and a small amount of time we are going
to have to approach it in an entirely
new way